which of the following functions are
continuous at x equals three
well as we said in the previous video in
the previous example in order to be
continuous at a point you at least have
to be defined at that point we saw our
definition of continuity f is continuous
at a if and only if
the limit of f as x approaches a is
equal to f of a
so over here in this case we could say
that a function is continuous at x
equals three
so f is a continuous
at
x equals three if and only if
if and only if the limit
as x approaches three of f of x
is equal to
f of 3.
now let's look at this first function
right over here natural log of x minus
3.
well try to evaluate and it's not f now
it's g try to evaluate g of 3 g of 3
right here g of three is equal to the
natural log of zero three minus three
this is not defined you can't raise e to
any power to get to zero you try to go
to you know you could say negative
infinity but that's not that's this is
not defined and so if this isn't even
defined at x equals 3 there's no way
that it's going to be continuous at x
equals 3. so we could rule this one out
now f of x is equal to e to the x minus
3. well this is just a shifted over
version of e to the x this is defined
for all real numbers and as we saw in
the previous example it's reasonable to
say it's continuous for all real numbers
and you could even do this little test
here the limit of e to the x minus three
as x approaches three well that is going
to be
that is going to be e to the three minus
three or e to the zero or one and so f
is the only one that is continuous and
once again it's good to think about
what's going on here visually if
if you like both of these are you could
think of a bit this is a shifted over
version of ln of x this is a shifted
over version of of e to the x and so if
we like we could draw ourselves some
axes
so that's our
y-axis
this is our
x-axis
and actually we draw some points here so
that's one
that is one
that is let's see two
three
two
and three
and let's see these are i said these are
shifted over versions so actually this
is maybe not the best way to draw it so
let me draw it this is one
two
three
four
five
and six and on this axis i won't make
them on the same scale let's say this is
one
two
3. i'm going to draw 1 2 3. i'm going to
draw a dotted line
right over here
so
g of x ln of x minus 3 is going to look
something like this if you put 3 in it
it's not defined if you put 4 in it ln
of 4 well that's sorry ln to 4 minus 1.
so that's going to be ln of uh sorry ln
of 4 minus 3 is actually just draw a
table here i know i'm confusing you
so
if i say x and i say g of x
so at three
you're undefined
at four this is
ln of one
ln of one which is equal to 0. so it's
right over there so
g of x is going to look something like
something like
that and so you can see at 3
it's you have this discontinuity there
it's not even defined to the left of 3.
now f of x is a little bit more
straightforward if you have so
e to the
3 is going to be
oh sorry f of 3 is going to be e to the
3 minus 3 or e to the 0 so it's going to
be
1. so it's going to look something like
this
it's going to look something
something
like
like that there's no jumps there's no
gaps
it is going to be continuous at frankly
all real numbers so for sure it's going
to be continuous at 3.